adam chitwood collider
hello adam andy buckley dunder mifflin
nice to meet you how are you
great thank you so much uh for taking
this time to talk to me today
uh i'm curious you know one of the
fun things about the office is there was
kind of a revolving door
of bosses that went throughout uh and
i'm curious from your perspective
uh who do you think david wallace's
favorite boss was to work for
or work with where oh michael scott come
on baby
happy michael scott easy enough you know
i should have i should have said yes to
the role and threat level midnight
you know yeah and i should not have sent
holly away i sent holly away because i
knew michael would leave i would have
missed him well that's true and
that brings up another question of you
know like uh
david makes some really good and really
smart decisions and then there are some
decisions like promoting ryan where
you're like what happened there
do you think david is a good boss or a
badass he's
he's he's a great boss i don't know if
he's a great cfo
that's fair he did technically like
bankrupt the company
right yes
and speaking of that one of my favorite
bits from the entire series is the suck
it song
um and i was wondering if you could walk
me through how that song worked was it
written did you guys write it
uh were you just kind of messing around
hold that oh there we go yeah no it you
know it was
yeah uh so warren lieberstein um
uh and halstead sullivan they're two
writers they i pretty they
they're the ones that wrote the the
lyrics to the song and they
you know they sent it over to me like
the morning of or like midnight the
night before i got it the morning of
uh we were filming all that stuff at my
house at my house
that day was just one long day
uh and john krasinski directed that
episode and it's funny i remember
thinking
man he he's really he's really like
seems to know what he's doing and he's
and he's just so full of enthusiasm and
stuff
i don't know what's happened to him
since the show um
nothing good he's just off doing
whatever he's doing something nice
married with kids
um but no so so they they did that and i
was like oh crap okay so i gotta come up
with a song for this all right so at
lunch
i was going just going over it on the
and i know like two chords on the piano
you know
whatever keyboards and uh and then we
did we did it so quickly it was we just
got super lucky
with that one take which is the take
because that was like the third take and
we were losing
like the time and the union rules and
blah blah look we got three minutes
let's go let's just keep it going you
know
and we just it was but it's so fun it's
such a fun song
yeah was there i i mean from your time
on the show
was there a favorite episode or like set
piece that was like the most fun to
shoot and then alternatively was there
one that was a little more challenging
or you were ready for that workday to be
over
uh i was never ready for the work day to
be over it was always just too much fun
um and i guess my wallace office in new
york was
i mean that's basically where i was the
first three two or three or four years
until i got to start coming to scranton
during the michael scott paper
company days um and the golden ticket
and all that um
but it was uh i mean so so that would be
it but i mean
i loved getting to go to scranton
finally when that would excuse me happen
because then
you know i was around everybody prior to
that it was just
one-on-one with steve and uh which is
obviously pretty good uh but then you
start feeling
i started feeling a little more a part
of the show
um when i got to go there and be there
and you know have
meetings with jim or you know or what
you know whatever
you know buy the michael scott paper
company however it was
yeah or sit in michael's it was always
fun sitting in michael's office across
from him
yeah it was always fun to see the and
how the dynamic in the office changed
when the big boss was
in the office how that shifted that was
the thing that's so much
so funny is when i tell people like i
was only i don't even think i did 40
episodes like what are you talking about
just because they referred to you know
david wallace is on the phone or you
know
all that so so much well thank you so
much for your time and
thank you for an iconic role that people
are still loving and talking about all
these years
that's wild but thank you adam thanks a
lot thank you have a good day